a high school teacher in suburban New
York the only openly right leaning
teacher at his school has been suspended
without pay for showing a Fox News
documentary about due process on college
campuses in class the story has been
gaining media attention over the past
week and it has a personal dimension for
me because he was my teacher he was the
teacher at my school we will speak with
Mike pop lardo about his suspension and
what it means for teachers and students
around the country then more stolen
valor from Nathan Phillips emerges a CNN
contributor compares a maggot to the KKK
hood and Alexandria Ocasio Cortez proves
herself to be the only honest radical
finally the mailbag I'm Michael Knowles
this is the Michael Noel's show
[Music]
this is a really really personal day to
me you know it's it's one of these
moments where you're reading the news
and I'm going I was actually going
through news on The Daily wire they do
it to do to do oh gosh a teacher was
suspended for having the audacity to
show a documentary from Fox News oh I
wonder who that oh and it's my teacher
okay and it's the one conservative not
even not it's not like the guy was you
know wearing a make America great again
hat in school he just showed both sides
of the political aisle which frequently
does not happen in education will speak
to him I can't wait to bring him on what
they're doing to him is awful and it's
not just him this is happening to
teachers around the country and it
leaves students poorly educated when
when teachers with different views of
politics and history are kept out it
leaves them poorly educated it also
leaves them feeling as though their
political views could get them lower
grades could hurt them in school could
make them face punishment it's a really
really serious thing so he'll come on
first let's make a little bit of money
honey with purple mattress you know how
I love purple so today at I don't know
1:30 in the morning Pacific time I woke
up and I did a news hit on one of the
morning news shows so I dragged myself
out of bed I come back I get to sleep
for an hour so in the old days I could
never get back to sleep but I have a
purple mattress and purple mattress is
the greatest mattress I've ever used
lulled me back to sleep and it's I mean
I truly feel so much better every day
because I sleep on it even sweet little
ELISA likes it it basically saved our
marriage you know that I can't but I
don't bring that much to the table here
but at least I can bring a purple
mattress and that that's something so
it's not quite a memory foam it's not an
innerspring mattress it's this new
technology they invented it it was
invented by a rocket scientist and it's
just fabulous it's firm and soft at the
same time how is it I don't know I don't
couldn't tell you I'm not a scientist I
just talk into a camera for a living
it's really really good the purple
mattress will feel different it will
feel unique and it's very breathable and
sleeps so cool 100 night risk-free trial
if you're not fully satisfied you can
return it for a full refund but you you
won't do that you will love it
backed by 10-year warranty free shipping
and returns you're going to love it
right now my listeners get a free purple
pillow with the purchase of a mattress
that's in addition to the great free
gifts they're offering site-wide text
cough FAC OVF EF e two four seven four
seven four seven the only way to get
this free pillow is to text Kofi faci of
EF EF e two four seven four seven four
seven Co V Fe Fe four seven four seven
four seven message and data rates may
apply they you know that's just life
you've got to pay your message and data
rates before we get to my teacher mr.
pop lardo just a little bit of news
we've covered the Covington boys giving
you updates every day and we called it
on the show he said I the guy said he
was a Vietnam Times veteran that Native
American man Nathan Phillips said it
sounds like he didn't serve in Vietnam
even though all the mainstream media
outlets said he's a Vietnam veteran he's
how dare are these kids harass a vietnam
vet so it turns out he didn't serve in
Vietnam he was in the Marines but he was
never deployed he never saw combat he
never went overseas to Vietnam
now the mainstream media then defended
him and said well he never said he was a
Vietnam veteran he never said that he
went overseas they say he said he was a
Vietnam Times veteran which is
technically correct that is except he's
also claimed to be a veteran who was in
the theater in Vietnam I'm a Vietnam vet
and I served in Marine Corps 72 to 76 I
got discharged
may 5th 1976 you know one of the I got
honorable discharge and one of the boxes
in there they talk it shows if he was a
peacetime or what my box says is that I
was in theater I don't talk much about
my Vietnam times it doesn't talk much
except on every television station that
will let him talk about it he doesn't
talk except when he's on Facebook that
he talked to me it does seem to talk
about it a lot it turns out that he was
not in the theater though he claims that
he was he's clearly this is a clear
example of stolen valor he's not just
claiming was a veteran he's not just
claiming he was a Vietnam veteran he's
claiming he was a Vietnam veteran in the
theater in combat which is demonstrably
not true he's elsewhere said that he was
a recon rain
sure actually he was a refrigerator
repairman
I'm actually not disparaging refriger
the military needs refrigerator
repairman that's honest work and he did
serve his country what I'm disparaging
is the lying the lying about it the
stealing valor and even beyond that look
this is a crazy person this is an insane
guy Nathan Phillips who lies about his
past lies about his military service
tries to bust in and break up Catholic
vigil masses starts banging drums in the
face of sixteen year olds this is a
bizarre man who clearly has a lot of
problems the real target of my ire is
the media the mainstream media who ran
with this they oh gosh he he's a he's a
hero he's in a Marriott hero was minding
his own business and then the kids came
and harassed in those evil catholic kids
they they use their assault smirks they
pulled out that off of the weapon of
mass destruction the sixteen-year-old
smirk oh wow awful to inflict that on
him and it's not true so the mainstream
media get it wrong okay fine the
mainstream media always get it wrong and
that's what people make mistakes it's
hard in reporting sometimes what I have
noticed however is that every time the
mainstream media gets something wrong
they get it wrong to favor left wingers
they never get it wrong to favor
right-wingers they never get the
narrative wrong such that it reflects
well on conservatives it they always get
it wrong in a way that reflects very
well on the left and very well on
Democrats and then they don't really
apologize when it turns out it's fake
news they just move on and misreport
another story
they just know well whoops too bad the
mainstream media constantly tell us that
they deserve our respect they're they're
so important they're defending democracy
they're there on the front lines and
they are the most wonderful people in
the whole world they have none of my
respect none not one iota not one ounce
certainly the American political media
some obviously some reporters around the
world wartime reporters they have a lot
of my respect a handful of reporters in
the United States sure the vast majority
statistically 100 percent of these
journalists have zero of my respect
that's fine
the reason they don't have my respect is
because they lie the way that this will
all make sense to you is when you
realize that the people on CNN and MSNBC
in the Washington Post and The New York
Times or wherever they are not
journalists they are Democrat political
operatives that's it I think we'll have
we've been saying this for years some
people think we're speaking
hyperbolically we're not they're they're
just operatives they're just hacks and
when you realize that when you realize
George Stephanopoulos was the Clinton
communications director when you realize
that Chris Cuomo is brother is Andy
Cuomo who just made infanticide legal in
New York and whose father was Mario
Cuomo who created the I oppose abortion
personally but I want it to be legal
line which now all of the moderate
Democrats have to tout when you realize
that they come from political operations
it will all make a lot more sense this
is the line that we're hearing now
between the mainstream media story and
the reality is that oh there were
competing narratives oh wow look people
see things differently through different
perspectives and you know maybe we
rushed a little mutt to push our
perspective and some people had other
perspective perspectives no that isn't
true that isn't true there are two
narratives
there's the mainstream media narrative
and there's the truth those are the two
and they're diametrically opposed to
each other certainly in this
circumstance what they're trying to do
to excuse their awful behavior is push a
tyranny of relativism to say well who
can really say what happened who knows I
mean yeah look okay so there are two
hours of video footage showing that the
Covington kids behaved admirably and
with great maturity and showing that
Nathan Phillips is a lying lunatic and
showing that the black Israelites are
horrible racist screaming at these white
gay okay there's a video that's one
perspective but I don't want it that to
be true that's I mean some of these
columns they posted they said look okay
the video shows one thing but we know
what we saw no you didn't look I know
what they saw too what they saw was what
they wanted to see but they didn't see
the truth it's this tyranny of
relativism this hysteria and this
primacy of feelings emotivism
rather than looking at objective reality
nowhere is this pleurer than on CNN on
Chris Cuomo's show he had a CNN
contributor Angela why come on to
compare the mag ahead to the KKK hood
but this make America great again hat is
just as maddening and frustrating and
triggering for me to look at as a KKK
hood like that is the type of hair tell
you that policies represent and until we
can have common ground and understanding
about that it that is that triggering
we're gonna continue to have problems
it's very triggering for her she thinks
of the Maggie hat as the KKK hood she
says as long as that's the case we're
gonna have problems right there is a
problem but that's a you problem
that's an Angela Wright problem that's a
left problem it's not my problem that
Angela Wray lives in a fantasy world
that's not my prop Angela rice feelings
are not my problem
the fact is a Maggie hat is not a KKK
hood in part because the maggot
represents the Republican Party in the
KKK hood represents the Democrat Party
there's nothing racist about making
America great again it's been a
Republican slogan now for 40 years Nixon
used it Reagan famously used it she says
that she can't be friends in this clip
with some air in this interview rather
she can't be friends with certain
conservatives if people were that she
can't be friends with them that's a you
problem sorry darling okay I mean grow
up I can't make you grow up I can't
resolve your daddy issues okay that's
not up to me I can't die not only am i
unwilling to do it I can't do I actually
can't do it you can't people will order
themselves toward virtue they will order
themselves toward discipline they will
order themselves toward recognizing a
moral standard or those standards will
be imposed from above by the government
or Butler by some giant oppressive force
that's the way it's going to happen the
the all of the the founding fathers
wrote about this especially John Adams
and Hamilton and some and a lot of the
Federalists they wrote about how if the
people loses it's
maturity its sense of discipline its
virtue its moral understanding its
religiosity its humility if the people
loses that it's all sunk we're all sunk
we just end up with this I can't argue
with Angela rise feelings they're her
feelings I can just point to reality and
when you look at the reality of that
video
those 16 year old Catholic school kids
were not the KKK they're not I'm sorry
I'm if maybe Angela Ryan needs to talk
it over with her therapist or something
I'm not a therapist I just I just talk
about politics I just I just try to
advance a conservative agenda which
which is based in reality it's not it's
based in objective reality not
subjective fantasy we've got a lot more
to get to but first let's make a little
money with Vohland branch Boland branch
sheets are there the second answer so
once you get that that wonderful
mattress and you can't just sleep on a
mattress you need to get nice sheets I
got to tell you when I was a bachelor I
would only buy the cheapest sheets
because I was a cheapskate and I'd be
like sandpaper I didn't realize that
there were gradations of sheets I am now
sold I am like forever into really
really nice sheets it totally changes
everything look if you're like me you
spend 28 hours of the day in bed so you
want to be comfortable for that getting
a great night's sleep is easier and more
affordable than you think
everything ballin branch makes from
bedding to blankets is made from pure
100% organic cotton they start out super
soft they get soft where's time goes on
usually when you buy luxury sheets you
can spend up to a thousand dollars in
the store Boland branch cuts out the
middleman and they get there only a
couple hundred bucks everyone who tries
them loves them they have thousands of
five-star reviews Forbes Wall Street
Journal Fast Company are all talking
about fold and branch even three u.s.
presidents sleep on Boland branch sheets
that's pretty impressive shipping is
free you can try them for 30 nights if
you don't love them send them back for a
refund but you will not want to send
them back to get started right now my
listeners get 50 bucks off your first
set of sheets it's a lot of money I'm
giving you 50 bucks you should enjoy
that you should thank me for the right
into the mailbag and thank me
$50 off your first set of sheets bow and
branch com promo code Michel mi CH AE L
Boland branch today 50 bucks off your
first set of sheets Bo ll and branch com
promo code Michael mi CH AE L Boland
branch
promo code Michael you might think that
the world is ending you might think that
we're living in an upside-down world I
have to give a compliment to Alexandria
ok Jie Cortese Alexandria okay Jie
Cortez is the only Democrat to vote
against reopening the government that's
the headline all the Democrats voted for
it other than Alexandria cassia Cortese
she voted against it because it funds
Immigration and Customs Enforcement and
she said she doesn't want to fund
immigration enforcement she wants to
abolish immigration enforcement and so
she voted against it at least she's
honest at least she's the only honest
radical in the Democrat Party they look
Nancy Pelosi and all those other
Democrats didn't really vote to reopen
the government president Trump has been
clear you have to fund with five billion
dollars out of it a budget that's over
four trillion dollars nearly four and a
half trillion dollars five billion
dollars for border security you've all
already voted for the border wall
Schumer Hillary Clinton Barack Obama all
these major Democrats voted for the
border wall 12 years ago now they're
saying it's immoral it's ineffective
it's costly so it's not none of that is
true we already have the wall we know
that the wall works we already parts of
the wall we know that the wall works
dramatically it reduces illegal
crossings by upwards of 90% where it's
been implemented it's not very expensive
the Democrats have voted not to reopen
the government in practice if they won't
include five measly billion dollars then
they they voted against it in practice
but they were being deceptive Alexandria
Ocasio Cortez is going a step further
she's saying look abolish ice abolish
immigration enforcement Democrats backed
off that that's their problem we need to
abolish it we need open borders we need
borders or immoral immigration
enforcement law enforcement is immoral
that's a radical position but at least
it's honest and at least you can have an
honest debate on it my kudos to her for
being honestly insane we got to bring on
my teacher mr. pop Laura Mike Pappalardo
is a veteran teacher from Fox Lane high
school that is my high school that's
where I went to or where I grew up K
through 12 and Bedford Central School
District he was my teacher he taught
economics and government while I was
there one thing
having been one of the few conservative
students I noticed that mr. pop lardo
was one of the few openly right-leaning
teachers that's not to say he was very
conservative you know all talking about
the Republican Party all the time or
anything but one thing I loved about his
class is he would listen to both sides
he would present both sides of an issue
which all too often in our educational
system doesn't happen now that
open-mindedness teaching an economics
and government class that
open-mindedness has gotten him suspended
for one month without pay and maybe
they're going to try to do even more to
him
it this is all over showing a
documentary produced by Fox News which
talked about due process on college
campuses and what college students are
gonna face when they go there we bring
on now mr. pop lardo mr. Pappalardo
thank you for being here
thank you for having me my god I gotta
tell you I didn't know this was
happening it's you know we haven't
talked in the number of years now I
didn't know this was happening until I
read about it on my own website one of
our reporters at the Daily wire wrote
about this and I am on it as a matter of
principle I'm so outraged that this is
happening to any teacher in the country
but in a personal level it really pains
me because I love that school district I
know you love the school district I was
as involved as any student wasn't you
know all of the student body president
well you were the advisor class
president all of the you know band
orchestra chorus top of the class all
these sort of things
I love the district and they are they're
acting so outrageously what is this
suspension about all right first I'm so
glad that you started with that because
I want to make it clear that I love the
families and students and at the benefit
as a school district they are great I've
appreciated every one of my 21 29 years
working as a factor in high school
teacher and this really just comes down
to a a small group of people that have
grabbed a hold of the reins of the
school district and are making some
really bad judgment calls here so uh so
I want to get into the details of the
action I do because what from what I
read on The Daily wire
what I read in your class you played
part a documentary that was produced by
Fox News on what students can expect on
college campus due process some of these
questions that are really in the news
they're really affecting our politics
today and then some of the political
forces at Fox Lane high school are
punishing you for that correct as a
matter of fact we probably have to go
back about six years ago to truly
understand what's happening so about six
years ago I went from being a closeted
conservative secretly listening to rush
and Hannity and occasionally using Fox
News program it as an instructional
device to be coming out at so to speak
because I was now serving as the Fox
Wayne High School Republicans Club
advisor that's when the way I was
treated by some in relatively few but
for Central School District and Fox when
high school leaders started to change
the way they treated me so fast forward
to you know to West May and what we have
is we have twelfth graders getting ready
to we Foxley in high school and as I and
many other teachers often do and wait
may with only a few days left to the
school years class days that is we start
planning what some of us including me
called bridge lessons the types of
things that will get kids to be able to
make the transition from the Bedford
bubble to the next part of their life
which is likely going to be college the
military the world of work and that plan
that type of lesson is not very uncommon
I've been doing it for 27 years
what changed this time however was a few
things one it was even today wasn't
included a Fox News documentary -
there's a new superintendent that had
not yet even finished his second year in
the school district and in my opinion
had not yet assimilated into the Bedford
Central School District family culture
degree there was a new principal that
also was a new to the school district
and had not yet completely assimilated
into the benefi Central School District
as a matter of fact those two gentlemen
that I just spoke are still commuting to
Bedford they haven't moved their family
into the district so
they're just coming in from outside
somewhere because this that what
surprised me so much about this story is
at least when I was there I guess I just
hosted my 10-year high school reunion I
guess when I was there I felt I was
obviously much more conservative than
anyone in the district but I didn't feel
that it was some oppressive environment
I didn't have a chip on my shoulder I
didn't feel that people were out to get
me or anything but what you're saying is
the new leadership has just come in and
they're they're clearly just if you look
at the timeline there what precipitated
some of this change yes absolutely it's
kind of a perfect storm you add into the
fact that we have some new to the
district commuters spending the
professional time on campus but their
personal time far away from campus add
to that that there was a conservative
teacher at the center of all this and
boom we have an explosion and the
explosion is charges drawn up against me
demanding a six month paid unpaid
suspension from Fox four in high school
in what would be my 30th year just one
year away from me being eligible to
fully retire and collect my full pension
it's it's absurd that that was what they
demanded again the alleged crime is
showing a Fox News documentary to 12th
grade students and providing an 60
minute discussion period to debrief that
video I wonder what would have happened
if you showed a documentary from CNN or
I wonder what would have happened if you
were the adviser to the young Democrat
club in that high school I think they
probably would have given you a raise I
think I wrote at least get a slap on the
back and maybe a picture on the website
okay it's amazing it's unbelievable and
it's it's such an outrage I was just
thinking you know when I was in your
class all of these students really liked
you left and right I mean I think I was
one of three conservatives maybe that so
most are on the left obviously but
what's so astounding about this is the
parallel that you see at colleges now
because we all know that the college
campuses have really decayed into a
politically toxic environment and a lot
of it is because they're bringing in the
outside Dean's and assistant Dean's and
deputy assistant deputy Dean's of
inclusion and political ideology and
they come in and they stir up trouble
and they try to be politically divisive
and push their own political agendas we
know that happens but you it's rare that
you hear stories about that happening in
high school I mean what what is the
shift here what is the fallout going to
be I just actually since I tweeted about
this I've gotten a lot of messages from
Fox Lane high school alumni and some
parents saying please cover this Michael
this is such an outrage what they're
doing to mr. pop lardo but you're
actually fighting back they did they
offer you any kind of deal or is this
now sort of out of everybody's hands I'm
so glad you brought that up because the
superintendent issued a two-page press
release and in it he lied about this
settlement that was offered and
challenged or imply to the public that I
refuse to take what was a reasonable
settlement offer so let me describe what
the real offer was and why I refused it
so first of all the real offer was that
I would agree that removing me as the JV
girls soccer coach should not be
challenged that that was the right thing
to do because of this Fox News
documentary number two that I should be
agreed to be removed from the JV
softball coach we agree to be removed as
the adviser to two clubs so agreed all
that waive or release statistics from
pending or future litigation and and and
that was absolutely unacceptable so
they're saying basically shut up and
take a huge because when you're coaching
Club coaching sports or you're advising
clubs that comes with some money so
they're saying take a pay cut and and
shut up and maybe we'll let you keep
your job yes and it's even worse than
that we've recently new and they should
have known immediately there was no way
I was going to accept that it's because
anyone that knows me knows that I'm a
person that's unyielding with my my my
sense of of morals and ethics I wasn't
going to agree to something that would
change me and make me a different and
weaker person
matter of fact the morning I went for
the first hearing my wife said to me
something that I'll never forget and
just paint the picture so I'm getting
dressed to get ready to go to this thing
throwing on a suit and a tie which I
hate wearing and my wife's getting ready
to go to work and she says to me Mike
you're a good man you did nothing wrong
don't let them break you we all love you
I am NOT going to let them break me and
I wasn't gonna greet at a ridiculous
settlement because doing so would have
broken me they are continuing to try to
break me but I wonder well that's what
it is they basically they say here's the
settlement here's the Faustian bargain
sell your soul and maybe we'll let you
continue to teach here as a shell of a
teacher it you know they this is what
happens when leftist ideologue come in
and try to stir up trouble and try to
push their agenda they fight so dirty
and this is as dirty as I've ever seen
anyone do it it would be one thing to go
after a first or second year teacher or
an unpopular teacher or a teacher who's
not involved in the school or a teacher
who's you know pushing his politics as
the only politics or anything you're
none of those things the school knows
that you're none of those things the
alumni know that you're none of those
things and the reason I bring it up
other than this personal issue is I
think that you're not the only person
that this has happened to around the
country you might be the only person
whose former student has a podcast where
you can talk about this but I think that
this is is probably happening in a lot
of other places and if you give up if
you took a settlement like that where
you're saying I I'm sorry Mia culpa Mia
culpa
I showed a documentary from a non
left-wing outlet I'm sorry I'm so I'll
never do it again
take my money take my coaching take my
school spirit take it all away please
please if you did that it would be so
demoralizing to other teachers who are
facing this problem and moreover it
would be demoralizing to students who
maybe are independent or right-leaning
or conservative but you were advising
the young Republican group on what is
the sense among the students all right
this is a very touchy question because
the students are outraged and I I I do
not want
students in the middle of a conflict but
it's unavoidable and the the not just a
young Republican students but students
you know at large are really trying to
reach out and support me they're doing
in a number of different ways and
they're actually comment on the Facebook
page today actually said I'm not the
Facebook page to GoFundMe page actually
said I'm trying to quote it well that's
right I should I should point out I did
see this on Facebook somebody else set
up a GoFundMe page because you're now
being suspended without pay and I
actually saw that you wrote somewhere on
it you said guys I'm a conservative I
feel really uncomfortable taking money
from people if I'm not doing work which
I thought was like the perfect
distillation of your political views
yeah as a matter of fact I'm putting
together some plans to earn the money
that's coming in through that go fund me
page more importantly than the money the
comments are amazing they're
heartwarming and you're exactly right
when this whole thing started it was it
was a struggle to defend my family and
my integrity but now that I see comments
coming from Texas and South Carolina one
person said Mr Pappalardo I don't know
you but we need people like you please
move to Texas and teach my kids this
you're right this is now becoming and
not not my I didn't intended to
obviously put a struggle to not only
defend myself and my family but to
defend some important principles that
all teachers fair-minded teachers should
respect that's absolutely right
unfortunately we're out of time but I'm
so glad that you could come on today and
and bring this up a little bit what I
love that district I mean I love my high
school I was involved in it as much as
anybody possibly could be and I am so
outraged as to what the Bedford Central
School District is doing right now I'm
outraged that this new superintendent
would allow this to happen or would
instigate this i personally am going to
give him a call to express my views as
an alumnus of the school and i encourage
other people to to express their outrage
at the obvious injustice that's being
done against you I'll obviously I'm
gonna be following this and I'm really
sorry it's happening to you you know
because obviously it's hurting you and
it's her
family and it's hurting your students
but I in in a sense I'm glad that some
light can be shed on this problem and
and the sort of degradation that people
who want to inject political ideology
and just to stir up a school district
the sort of degradation that they're
doing to their to education and to their
districts mister Pappalardo it's great
to see you and I'll talk to you soon
thank you so much all right we got to
get to the mailbag but first if you are
on facebook or youtube go to daily
wire.com check it out it's ten bucks a
month $100 for an annual membership if
you already subscribed thank you very
much you keep the lights on you keep
khofifah in my cup if you don't head
over there you get the and reclaim and
show the ben shapiro show my show the
Matt Walsh show backstage you get to ask
questions in the mailbag yet ask
questions backstage you get another
Kingdom you get the leftist here's
tumblr this is so important this
Stumbler mmm that's really that's the
Angela Wray
that's a nice Angela rye it tell you
it's not a scotch it's not an Angela
bourbon it's not it's not it's an Angela
rye mmm so delicious mmm yeah tastes
like pretty sordid fantasies and really
strange personal issues go over to Daly
we're calm we'll be right back with the
mailbag
all right we're getting through them
today I always take too long so I'm
gonna try to fly through them from Paula
listen Michael I don't usually bother to
write to anybody about this but I like
you and I think you can go far in life
it's the students are all right to words
not the students are all right al ri ght
xoxoxo i did an episode a few days ago
called the kids are all right al righ T
you're correct about how to spell the
word all right
however where you are incorrect is that
the reference that I was making is to a
song by the who called the Kids Are
Alright which spells the word albeit
incorrectly al ri ght I appreciate your
concern and your attention to grammar
but the reference was to pop culture
which so often gets language wrong from
Nicole hi Michael do you have any
opinions on the drinking age in the u.s.
I'm currently in college and I see 18 to
20 year olds go to outrageous parties
constantly putting themselves in
dangerous situations simply because they
want to drink most friends I ask say
they would prefer to have a safer night
drinking with a close group of friends
if they were able to just buy alcohol
themselves would you argue for a
drinking age of 18 or do you think the
drinking culture in America is not
suitable for an age that young thanks I
100% support a drinking age of 18 I
think it's absurd that peeping age is 21
I certainly drank at 18 I know everybody
else that I knew drank at the age of 18
just about you can serve your country at
the age of 18 but you can't have a drink
that is so absurd and if you were going
to all those outrageous parties where
people are putting themselves in
dangerous situations you may have seen
me there I don't know when you were in
college if it was around the same time
maybe we saw each other I'm sorry if I
was drinking too much I like beer
I still like beer and more importantly
it's important to teach kids how to
drink responsibly I come from an Italian
family Italian family that lets you have
wine at dinner sometimes from when
you're like 7 years old onward and what
this teaches you over time is how to
drink responsibly what your limits are
how to drink so that you don't
get drunk if you do get drunk to know
how to stop and be safe about things
like that and that's very important when
I got to college a lot of the people
there a lot of my friends had never been
allowed to drink even a sip of alcohol
in their lives they're the ones who went
to the hospital they're the ones who
went to the health centers they're the
ones who got into a lot of trouble
whereas if you've had some experience
and you know your limits
maybe you push your limits a little too
far sometimes but you're you're able to
just be a little more safer and a little
more mature I also of the opinion that
if you raise kids with respect and you
raise them with expectations that are
mature and expectations of people to
behave in a civilized and adult way
they're more likely to rise to that
expectation
I've just seen that anecdotally so you
bet 18-year old drinking age cool for me
from Austin hello Michael I recently
watched your panel from politican and at
one point you were accused of being
inconsistent because you're pro-life and
for the death penalty do you think it's
inconsistent to hold both of those views
at once how do you feel about the
current death penalty system in the US
yeah this is this one actually really
bothers me because I only saw this after
the fact on the tape the panel you're
talking about I was with a few liberal
guys from YouTube and Charley Kirk was
there and that CNN guy what's his name
Bakari sellers and so we're sitting
there the hole was so gigantic that you
couldn't really hear anybody on these
panels so one guy I guess at the very
end said that I was being hypocritical
for being for opposing abortion but
supporting the death penalty and I just
couldn't hear it so I couldn't give him
a snarky response but I will now there
is no disagreement whatsoever there is
no hypocrisy there is no contradiction
it is perfectly reasonable to believe
that the state has the authority to
impose capital punishment which has been
widely believed for all of human history
which has great scriptural legal
theological moral ethical foundation and
also it's wrong to kill babies in New
York State now you can kill a baby on
the day he's born just right before he
comes out of the womb you can snip snip
and you can kill that baby you can
commit infanticide in New York that's
that's obviously very wrong the reason
that this is wrong is because it's an
innocent little baby and an innocent
little baby is very different than a
convicted murderer who has had the right
to due process but if you're looking at
some for just some little legal
mechanism due process would be one of
them
you can kill people with the state at
least can kill people with due process
that innocent little baby hasn't
committed any crime he certainly hasn't
had a trial by a jury of his peers he
hasn't been convicted he hasn't been
given any sort of due process but of
course beyond that we know that capital
punishment has three purposes a
retributive which is just punishing it
being the criminal because he's
committed an injustice
then there's the deterrent effect to
deter people from committing future
crimes and then there's the
rehabilitative effect this obviously
services starts to go away when you're
talking about killing the criminal
however as dr. Johnson famously observed
hanging concentrates the mind when a man
knows he's to be hanged in a fortnight
it concentrates his mind wonderfully
there is a little rehabilitative effect
at least to that retribution is the
purpose of criminal justice it's about
justice it's not just about
rehabilitation it's not that's what it's
about they've committed a crime and now
they are able to be killed only the left
could confuse a convicted murderer
convicted rapist with an innocent little
baby they confuse it because they're
being obtuse because they want to
confuse it because they want to put
their heads in the sand but it's absurd
and I think the reason that you see the
left using all of these euphemisms for
abortion is they say women's
reproductive health women's right to
choose they never talk about abortion or
killing per se the reason they use those
euphemisms is because they do understand
the distinction and it makes them very
uncomfortable from william michael
knowles is a critic of modernity a
history buff and a staunch papist what
is your take on monarchism the Catholic
Church has canonized several kings such
as Stephen of Hungary and Fernando the
third well the famous Catholic
philosopher Saint Thomas Aquinas
concluded the monarchy was the best form
of government perhaps it is true after
all our Lord is himself the King of
Kings as an American a Republican and a
Catholic what do you make of monarchist
thanks in advance depends on the
monarchy I don't know what which
monarchy are we talking about politics
is very important when in in its
particulars in its tradition we don't
have a tradition of the monarch in
America it would be very strange to
impose a tradition of a monarchy now
some of the Federalists wanted a
monarchy when the country was being
founded perhaps they could have done
that perhaps that would have not
succeeded as James ii of england is a
great monarch I support that monarch
certain monarchs gain monikers like the
Terrible you know Ivan the Terrible or
whatever those might not be great
monarchs at all the form of government
depends on history and tradition and the
culture of the people there are some
Universalists who political
Universalists who say a particular form
of liberal democracy is the only
legitimate form of government that has
to exist ever in every single place and
if any government differs in any way if
england has a constitutional monarchy or
any other country then that is somehow
unjust and wrong that's absurd I mean
that is just a leftist rationalist
nonsense one reason why it's probably
good we don't have a king in America is
because we have such an ethic of
liberalism and democracy into Galit
arianism that I don't know if we made
Alexandria Ocasio Cortes our or Queen
I'd probably I'd probably finally move
up to Canada and then Elizabeth would be
my queen but people who take that
Universalist approach to politics are
being too simplistic about it and
they're being too narrow both as a
matter of time and as a matter of
political philosophy from David hail the
king of trolls given the controversy
surrounding the Covington Catholic
students what would your reply be to one
of the protesters words that the white
students go back to Europe oh that's
right one of the guys with that Indian
phony but Nathan Phillips he yelled go
back to Europe my reply would be no I'm
not from Europe I was born in America
America is my native land I'm a Native
American I'm just as much a Native
American as any of those guys are this
issue of stealing land this is the new
line America's stolen
land stolen from whom who is it stolen
from I guess technically most
immediately it was stolen from the
British and then the British stole it
from the Dutch and then I don't know the
Iroquois stole some land from a lot of
their neighbors the Comanche stole land
from the Apache the leap on Apache stole
land from the Cheyenne I don't know the
Aztecs expanded pretty quickly who did
they steal land from whose land is it
that's absurd
that's a ridiculous question Nathan
Phillip standing there in the middle of
our nation's capital saying this is our
land go back to Europe I'm not from
Europe you go back to Europe go enjoy
Europe have a good time see if they deal
with your Looney tune drum banging in
their face go move to Italy see what
happens if you bang a drum in the face
of some italian guy not going to end
well from Andrew hey Michael
right now if the pro-life movement were
to succeed would we not have a major
problem on our hands dealing with
underage girls getting pregnant from
failing with safe sex which i think is
the lead cause of all or at least most
of the abortions in this country no we
wouldn't and no that is not the lead
cause of abortions in this country
according to the Guttmacher Institute
which is a pro-abortion Research
Institute it used to be part of Planned
Parenthood the vast majority of abortion
patients are in their twenties or higher
so over 50% of them are in their 20s 34
% of abortion patients are aged 20 to 24
I think about 27% of that are 24 and
above the people who are aged 17 or
younger so what you're talking about
underaged girls or minors is that makes
up just 3.2 percent of abortions
about 97% of abortions are taken by
girls who are not minors it's just
another one of these myths legends of
the the pro-abortion movement see oh
it's all it's all just these poor
underage girls who don't know any better
who are desperate or - no that's not
true it's mostly just people in their
20s who don't want to have a child and
so they'd rather
kill it than have it that's a sad fact
but it's important to name these
statistics since row v Wade sixty
million kids have been killed unborn
babies thirty million of whom roughly or
women it's important to point at the
reality of abortion versus the myth they
say oh gosh before Roe vs. Wade
five thousand to ten thousand women a
year would die from back-alley abortions
that's not true the guy who came up with
that statistic who was the founder of
nay RAL dr. Bernard Nathanson admitted
that was a total lie the actual number
which we had from the CDC is that thirty
nine women died that year from illegal
abortions and twenty four women died
that year from legal abortions and
statistically speaking because abortion
was still illegal in thirty states it
was just as dangerous to get a legal
abortion as it was to get an illegal
abortion a lot of lies that the
pro-abortion movement is made up of lies
it's based on lies and it's advanced by
lies and I think those lies are finally
being exposed they're being exposed by
the sonogram most importantly and
they're being exposed by statistics from
Michael hi Michael hi Michael like
another subscriber said I came for Ben
but stayed for Michael that's very nice
in your podcast about the State of the
Union I got the impression that you
don't like Thomas Jefferson was my
impression correct if so why aren't you
so enamored of him thanks for all your
free labor at the Daily wire my pleasure
it's not that I hate Thomas Jefferson I
like Thomas Jefferson perfectly well
he's a complicated man and obviously a
genius but Thomas Jefferson does
represent the beginning of the American
left Thomas Jefferson Thomas Paine the
anti-federalists they represent
basically the early stages of the
American left and the American right are
represented the Conservatives in America
are represented by John Adams probably
most importantly and Alexander Hamilton
and James Madison the people who wrote
the Federalist Papers of course that
that is a distinction and when you hear
of Thomas Jefferson writing about how we
should have a revolution every dozen
years and how the tree of liberty must
be quenched in the blood of patriots and
tyrants when you're here writing all of
these Tom Paine like screeds you just
think that this is a guy who
gotten lost in the ideology of
rationalism this is a guy who supported
the French Revolution who which of
course led to the guillotine led to the
terror oh he's a guy who just went a
little bit wrong in his ideologies so I
still love him he's still a father of
the country but as far as the
philosophical founders of of the country
of our Constitution and of the the good
parts of American philosophy and our
doctrines that goes to the Federalists
okay we got a lot more to talk about but
unfortunately we're at a time have a
good weekend enjoy check out another
Kingdom we got the audio book of that
coming out soon in the meantime I will
see you on Monday I'm Michael Knowles
this is the Michael Nolt show
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Robert Sterling executive producer
Jeremy Moore senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
clever and our technical producer is
Austin Stephens edited by Dani D'Amico
audio is mixed by Dylan case production
assistant Nick shyam hair and makeup is
by Jessa alvera the Michael Noel's show
is a daily wire production copyright
daily wire 20 19